- I love, this is my favorite part, every,
cause I asked John, I was
like, who's filming, here?
And he was like, it's usually me.
I think it's awesome, if
you're making fun of him,
and he's filming.
- I know, people always think we have
a third party filming us for these things,
and I'm like, no, we just live
together, and he films me.
I force him to do it.
But, honestly, all my awards
are so silly, usually,
and this baby to baby one
meant the world to me.
So, it was, it was fun to move
around his awards for him.
- He had enough up there.
- He has enough!
- Yes!
- I have like a Victoria Secret Best Hair,
Hottest Chip Award, and
Best Mac and Cheese.
- First of all, I would love your awards,
to have won those awards.
(laughs)
I got like 64 on like, some kind of late,
like way back in the 100's, like,
on like, for Maxim when I was 24,
and I was like, yes!
And it was like, legit, like 80.
It was like 80 out of 100.
That's the saddest number.
- You know how many
times I submitted myself
to be a Maxim hometown hottie?
It was like, please pick me,
please pick me, and then, yeah,
I didn't get it.
- You have the greatest
personality of anyone.
- Thank you!
- Is that why you think
people are just so fascinated
with you online?
- I don't know, I think they're fascinated
by the fact that John and I are
two incredibly different people.
And his tweet will be
like so serious, and so,
whether it's devastating, or impactful,
mine will always be so stupid, so.
- I love it, it's a nice juxtaposition.
- Yes, it is.
- I think people love
your honesty, though.
Have you ever hesitated,
cause I've done this,
where I write something, and
then I'm like, no delete.
- Yeah, well now, I used
to be insane on Twitter,
but now I definitely think about it,
and I think about the way we present it.
And I ask John, like, do you
think this is a good idea?
And sometimes he'll
say, if you believe it,
then it's fine, but if
it's gonna, you know,
really affect you after then
maybe, try to hold back.
But, with celebrities,
it's good to just apologize
for being a (beep) idiot.
(laughs)
(applause)
I think like, I think it's very possible
to do a very human, like,
apology and say like,
wow, I'm so sorry that I was
this dumb, in this moment,
and I didn't think about this person,
that person, this person.
My mistake, I'm gonna learn from this,
and we're gonna move on.
I think more people need to do that,
and instead of like, I'm sorry I hurt you.
- People do like to talk about the harm
of social media a lot, but,
scrolling through your posts,
I just see all the good that it can do.
For example, it can show people
how to be patient parents.
Look at this video of Chrissy
negotiating with Luna,
which I think all of us
moms and dads can relate.
- I now call to order,
the meeting of the candy.
First off, Luna, I
would like you to speak.
Tell me about why you deserve the candy.
- I want the candy cause I want it.
- [Chrissy] What are you going to do
if I give you the candy?
- Eat it.
- No, I mean are you gonna be good?
- [Luna] Yeah!
- How about, let's go
into negotiations now.
How about,
- [John] How many pieces of candy?
- How many pieces of candy?
I say one, what do you say?
- I say like, this.
- [Chrissy] Three?
That's a good negotiation.
All right, what about, one?
- No, I want three.
(applause)
- She knew what she wanted.
- I know, I just love John egging her on.
John's like, that's reasonable.
Whatever.
- But the sexiest man alive isn't above,
this is one of my favorite things,
he's not above performing
while drunk either.
And I love that you videoed this.
This is my favorite
thing you've ever done.
This happened just last month.
♪ Cause all of me ♪
♪ Love my curves and all my edges ♪
♪ All my perfect, imperfections ♪
♪ I give my all to me ♪
- Oh, my god, it's the best.
It's the greatest video.
- The best is he was trying to be,
like, I saw Oz was having a
sale on onesies so I was like,
let's get, they're seven dollars.
Let's get onesies.
And so we got the onesies,
then we decided to go to Universal.
And then, I said, let's go incognito,
and wear these onesies, and
no one will know who we are.
And John picked the one
with his face on it.
- [Kelly] First of all, I
love that he found a onesie
with his face on it, that's amazing.
- Yeah, it literally
says I love John Legend
and his face.
And we were like, no one
will know who we are.
- He's completely MC Hammered,
like singing that song.
- But the initial thought behind this was
that the stage was empty,
so I thought it'd be funny
if John got on stage,
and I filmed him performing to nobody.
And then the second he hit a note,
everyone flooded over,
so it was not meant to be a nice thing.
Sprinkle, sprinkle,
sprinkle, just a little bit.
(laughs)
Some of you have been around
since my very first tiny, tiny website.
It was like a WordPress Blog.
I updated it from my phone.
I've been wanting to do a real website,
where it was a true community of people
that love Cravings, love the
cookbooks, love the cookware.
Just a place where you
could see everything
that is our family.
We wanted to share everything
in one little spot for you guys.
- Bye, Luna.
- Bye, oh, okay, goodbye.
- Welcome back!
If you've been craving more Chrissy Teigen
in your life, you are in luck,
because she just launched her new website
and the fan collection
for her Cravings line,
which I love.
- Thank you so, they sent you a basket so,
I was like, don't feel any
pressure to post anything,
because I just wanted people to have it,
and sometimes I'm like, oh my god,
they think I want them to
post it, and I'm so mortified.
- No, I didn't get your basket until late
in the game, cause we
had been in Tennessee.
So, I had already bought stuff at Target.
Like I filled up my whole
buggy, as I do, at Target.
But here is a photo of you right
after you launched your website.
So, what's, what's happening here?
- Oh, yeah, this is me
working the controls.
Just casually.
No, we crashed, which is amazing,
cause I posted it on Twitter and Instagram
at the same time, cause I'm stupid.
- No, no, no, no, no ma'am.
Many people post on Twitter and Instagram
at the same time and they
don't break the internet.
- But I was like, every
body flood my website,
and then they did, and it's
honestly, it was incredible.
It was awesome, because it's
such a true labor of love.
Like, we were so happy
to do it for everybody,
and I've never had a website except
for like a tiny little blog
in the very, very beginning
of John and I's dating life,
and then this has just
transformed into a team,
but also very personal to me, so.
- I love it, its very inclusive.
So, why did you want to create a website,
since you're already
on social media a lot?
- Well because, Twitter is one thing.
Instagram is another thing.
And then, having a community
where there's people
that enjoy the same things
as you is very different.
So, there's Twitter, where you
are basically attacked a lot.
- Yeah, I don't know what you mean.
- You never get attacked on
Twitter, that's so crazy.
- People just love every thing I do.
- Yeah, I have a heavy
filters on trust me.
- Did you not hear that John
and I ruined Christmas recently?
- Oh yeah, you did ruin Christmas!
- I was like, how did I mess that up?
- You guys are such, I know.
Sharon Osborn, man, she hates you guys.
- And I was like, she was just on my show!
And I was like wait, what?
I was like, people got
so mad cause we changed,
he had this idea because
of the Me Too movement,
they pulled Baby It's Cold Outside
from any radio, like a lot of
radio stations at Christmas.
Well, I love that song.
- Well, yeah, but then Sharon assumed
that you guys burned them all
in the backyard or something,
like they can never listen
to the original ever again.
- And both John and I have actually cut
Baby It's Cold Outside the original,
and we like the original,
but we noticed that a
lot of people didn't.
So we were like, oh let's
just give them another option,
or whatever.
And apparently, we killed Christmas.
- You guys killed Christmas.
- I mean, I literally
woke up the next day,
and I was like
- If I can't have my creepy
song, it's not Christmas.
- I want the date rape drink.
- I want date rapey songs.
- I was like, and honestly,
the original doesn't even offend me.
I just was like, cool
we'll do another version.
- Exactly, like, I'm not offendable.
Like, I hear it all,
it's hard to offend me.
I wasn't mad about the song,
I don't care what you guys do.
But to be like, oh, I
hate this now, oh my god.
Get over it.
- Yeah, its so weird.
- Go off, Sharon.
- I love Sharon, no, but here's the thing,
she actually said, and she
means it, like she loves y'all.
That's why I thought it was so weird.
Like she took it so personal.
Like, I just thought it was weird.
Like, but, here's the thing,
I actually love her, I do.
She came on here and I
was like, I love her.
I think she is so funny.
But then I was like, we
didn't kill Christmas.
- You're nicer than me, man.
- Well cause I'm tryin' to understand it,
because I'm like there's so many issues
in the world right now, I mean,
- No, I want my creepy song!
- It's like, it's so weird.
Anyway, you posted a pic of
your holiday table, though.
And I really want to know
this, did you make all that?
- [Chrissy] Oh, you know what?
Okay, so this I posted, so,
every single dish on this table,
I've actually made for
Thanksgiving many, many times.
I've never made this many at once.
I wanted to show people everything,
so that they could be able
to piece together their menu.
- The picture's gorgeous.
- Yes, yes, and it was important to me
that it wasn't like all edited together.
I wanted to shoot them all together,
and then we ate this all
at the end of the night.
So I've had three Thanksgivings this year.
- And that, the burlap it's so nice.
- Yeah, I'm very proud of it.
- All right, so what's new?
Because I already have most
of your Cravings Collection
at Target.
So, what's new in your fall collection?
- So I have this dutch
oven, which is, to me,
is like super, super easy.
I do a lot of soups and stews.
This tagine is my prized possession,
because this is inspired
by many trips to Morocco.
This shape here, ensures that
moisture distributes evenly
within the pot, and you can transfer it
from oven to stove top,
or stove top to oven.
And everything's super,
super tender after.
- I want you to teach me how to cook.
- Oh, I would love to.
- I don't cook well.
- Can we just wear robes at
my house, and I will do it?
- I only hang out with people
that don't wanna get dressed up.
- Amazing!
- Any time people are like,
let's go out on the town,
I'm like, eh, that was 22.
- I don't think I've ever
seen photos of you out.
- I don't go out.
- I love that!
- No, I'm literally you, like
I'm, well a little different,
but our personalities are very similar.
- We are so similar, which
is why I'm team Kelly
on The Voice.
- So, what, is that the wok?
- And then this stainless
steel wok is my prized,
honestly, to me this is
such a beautiful gift,
which is why I thought it'd be
the perfect audience member gift,
which is why we are giving
it to everybody here!
(crowd cheers)
- All right, does that include me?
- Yes, I think so.
- Okay, I want one!